he was kind of like the Joker we're
eating easy cheese for the first time
she's that's easy I know that it comes
from a can and squirted straight I think
kids at school had it and it was one of
those things that I wanted but my mom
wouldn't let me have first most American
day was when I got my US citizenship and
then the second one is the day I get to
try ez cheese like whipped cream
basically right we have a choice of
American versus cheddar it's amazing
made with real cheese
so that's comforting also excellent
source of calcium ready yeah oh my hands
shaking it's not easy for YB it's like
half and half it's like a little pizza
[Music]
Fluffy's I hope that was easy
you know cheese will stick kind of stock
to the roof your mouth Jenna what what
are you doing I'm chopping you with my
cheese hands easy I like this this is
like a friend activity yeah I don't
think you should take this straight to
your face
cheese C's T's T's delicious one two
three four I declare cheese bar I think
I'll get like a little mountain just all
right oh you got pretty far you got I
feel like here now we do your space so
here touch our tips on what don't laugh
too much they're connected look why so
serious
I like this cheese I would have been in
love with this as a kid how do you feel
like your life has changed for the
better today I think my life just got
easy or it just got cheesy America is a
melting pot and we're living simplifying
that I know she's form o we are America
all at once
get out of your cans guys yes everyone
and come join us
[Music]